Darth Vader has stood the test of time as
one of the greatest villains in movie history.
Yet for all the Star Wars baddie's fame and
popularity, Disney doesn't seem to have any
intention of giving Darth Vader his own movie
despite mining Star Wars lore for all sorts
of other spinoffs and prequels.
Why?
Here's a look at some of the reasons Disney
won't give Darth Vader his own movie.
Been there, done that
So far, Disney's stand alone Star Wars spin-offs
have been prequels that fill in gaps in franchise
history.
Rogue One explained how the Rebellion got
the Death Star plans in A New Hope, while
Solo explores the early life of everyone's
favorite scruffy nerf herder.
But there's not all that much left to tell
about Darth Vader's past, because the prequels
went into great detail about exactly how and
why Anakin Skywalker grew up to become Darth
Vader.
Even the gap between the prequels and the
original trilogy has been filled in some thanks
to shows like Star Wars Rebels.
And even if they wanted to revisit Vader's
early days, there's one big problem…
Anakin Skywalker ruined Darth Vader
Few things kill the mystique and awe associated
with a legendary villain like seeing him as
a love-stricken, whiny teenage brat.
Sure, it made some sense that Anakin had anger
issues - he did fall to the Dark Side, after
all.
But while the journey of Anakin to Vader could
and should have been compelling, the actual
story on screen was anything but.
On the plus side, thanks to his burned-up
body being forever locked away in a robotic
suit, Darth Vader never had to worry about
feeling sand ever again.
But the prequels also killed fan interest
in seeing Anakin ever again.
A little bit goes a long way
Remember all those other Star Wars projects
we mentioned?
Well, they're set early enough for Darth Vader
to be an active villain, allowing for plenty
of cool moments like his scene-stealing cameo
in Rogue One.
And if there's one thing the prequels taught
everyone, it's that Vader actually works best
in small doses.
If you look at the original trilogy, Vader
actually doesn't appear on screen very much.
For example, it's estimated that he only appears
in 12 minutes of A New Hope.
With Vader, less is more, and the looming
threat of him appearing makes his eventual
appearance all the scarier.
A full length Vader spotlight film would go
against decades of tradition, while also working
against the character's strength.
After all, as we learned from the prequels,
familiarity breeds contempt.
So for now, fans will have to settle for Darth
Vader being used as a plot device to drive
other stories - and that is probably for the
best.
The rise of other Star Wars villains
While films like Solo seemed designed to mine
Star Wars nostalgia, that nostalgia can only
take you so far, which is why movies like
The Last Jedi have worked so hard to break
from tradition and establish something new
and different.
While Vader might be iconic, he also now belongs
to the past.
And with Disney working to establish new villains
in the films like Kylo Ren, Captain Phasma,
and General Hux - not to mention new villains
in the comics like the morally ambiguous Doctor
Aphra - putting the spotlight back on the
previous generation of villains like Darth
Vader seems counterproductive.
James Earl Jones
As much as we love James Earl Jones as Darth
Vader, we have to face reality: he won't be
around forever.
And does anybody really want to see a Darth
Vader film where Vader is voiced by anyone
except Jones?
With Jones now in his late 80's, and no Vader
film currently in development, it's very possible
that Disney may decide out of respect for
Jones and his fans to squelch any future plans
for a Vader solo film.
"I have one thing to say to people like you…
I LIKE STAR WARS TOO!"
The past is the future is the past
Let's face it: Hollywood is a reboot-happy
place.
The odds favor currently popular franchises
being remade within a decade or two.
So could the much reviled Star Wars prequels
get a complete overhaul too?
Think about it: no poorly acted, petulant
Anakin Skywalker, no Jar Jar Binks, and no
midi-chlorians.
Nope, none of it ever happened.
Wiping the slate clean and rebooting the prequels
by replacing them with a Vader solo franchise
might be the best chance the character has
at getting his own film - and fixing the mistakes
of the past at the same time.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!